Up at the top, we clearly have
the top level heading, The Funion.
That's an h1.
Next, we have In the News.
This is quite small, but
actually if you look at it in dev tools,
you'll see that it's an h2.
It's important that you don't fall into
the trap of using these heading tags
just to achieve a particular
look on the page.
Sometimes we see people using heading
tags where they want some large text for
something like a pull quote, and it can
create quite a confusing experience.
Or in a case like this, they might
think that because it's smaller
that it should be a lower heading level.
But actually,
since it's operating as a section title,
it should definitely be a level
two heading on this page.
Next we have the headline about cats.
That's an h3 on this page, because
it's inside the In the News section.